look youtube
let's wait for a few people to get in
here and then
we shall talk honesty on a friday night
you know
existentialism on prom night that kind
of stuff hello
welcome to my stream it's friday night
and we're here to talk about
comma because we're on the official kami
youtube channel
dot com ai archive which is actually an
unofficial youtube channel
but they do a better job being my social
media
manager than i will ever be
and hopefully they're making buku
dollars
off the advertising revenue
what's up what's up okay first thing to
talk about
on discord today you know it is
interesting it's interesting to see the
vibe of new discord
with the slow mode in the lobby i mean
you have to do it right as the company
scales you have to do it it's honesty on
a friday night
um you can't keep going on
uh like you were going because if you
keep going on like
we're going you're never going to grow
you're never going to be more
and me i'm a big fan of growth uh
so boring though i know it is boring
right i know i know but
i mean that's part of becoming a real
company
um i think we're barely gonna hit four
million dollars in revenue this year
hopefully you guys come through buy some
common twos especially when that zero
eight is going to be released
um next year we're hoping for 10 million
in revenue
i think we can do it we have some ideas
um yeah i mean that's look hockey stick
growth isn't real
exponential growth is real um
i don't chronovirus don't worry boys
uh hello from russia
uh you know youtube doesn't really you
guys got to hit that bell you guys got
to hit that bell on the subscribe menu
i'm sure you're the 31 who did this
doesn't notify people nearly as fast i
get way more on instagram and twitch
um maybe she's done this on twitch but
no we're here to talk about comma and
we're here to talk about honesty you
know
for the first time working at calm is
not so terrible you know i hated it i
hated it last year
you guys remember that stream from july
where i was like holy [ __ ] we're gonna
fail
you know we're gonna be on one of them
failed startup blogs you guys can
make fun of me in hacker news comments
but like
you know we're not gonna fail anymore
[ __ ] we might even win um i did lex
friedman this week
so that was nice lex figmen's a great
guy man
real positive energy you know
uh
we are hiring we are hiring we're not
hiring for a bodyguard we are hiring for
an
office manager um now remember as an
office manager if you think you're going
to come in and get coffees and [ __ ]
no no no no trust me the questions are
still really like
pretty much just what's your iq um
but you know now they're they're you're
gonna be asked the same sort of
questions right
they're not math-based they're more
based
uh when am i doing jre uh yo that's a
red light
nebulae uh never doing jerry
i can go into why but yeah i know if
you're not a programmer and you're
interested we do have an
office manager position uh that we're
hiring for
what's the reason that we're more
positive that i'm more positive than
last year
because we're gonna win boys
like kama's gonna win um
yeah no the problem with uh jre is uh
you know it kind of defines you that
doing that podcast becomes who you
are um look i mean joe logan's great but
he's not a technical guy uh and a lot of
my analogies and a lot of my thought
processes
are tied into to to technical stuff
but all right we're here to talk about a
few other comma things so you know look
look look look look
research research research 079 came out
zero seven nine came out shout out
look it's you know it's a deeb who did
that release
um if you guys know a deeb uh
willem's been working on a secret comma
project
um a little helped out with the release
a bit but that release was really a deep
you know
the fact that he's got cpu down so much
guess what's coming out in
zero seven ten
we are down clocking the comma two cpu
not just one notch not just two notches
but for the big core three notches we're
going down three notches we're going
down to 1.44 gigahertz
and you guys are like what that shitty i
get a slower product
no you get a product that doesn't
overheat anymore
um and we've done it in such a way that
the
cpu usage on zero seven ten is going to
be lower than the cpu usage
on zero seven eight despite being down
clocked three notches
um so huge victory from a deep uh and
that's what's coming in zero seven ten
zero eight is the new model guys i know
the new model the new models are delayed
way more than i would like there's a
branch there's a branch on open pilot if
you want to drive with the new model
it's [ __ ]
um we did
some big refactors
both conceptual refactors the model
reasons completely in three dimensions
now not in two dimensions but of course
you know three dimensions instead of two
dimensions that's three times
the bugs and you're like you know why is
it three times the bug [ __ ] man
it's not even you know it's okay maybe
not three times but it's a lot more bugs
um you know because you know no no it is
three times the bugs because normally
you're just off in like
one yaw but now you got your pitch and
roll to be often
you can make mistakes in all three
dimensions
instead of really effectively what's one
um
so it's three times the bugs we got a
lot of bugs to fix we've also migrated
all of our stuff from tensorflow over to
pie torch
so that's been a big you know now you
got all the pie torch bugs too so we
gotta fix those bugs
we're moving off a stack that's
crap code but uh you know worked
because we riced it to [ __ ] uh versus
you know a new stack which is clean
which is well written but there are
gonna be bugs so it is gonna take some
time
um so that zero eight there's gonna be
at least a zero seven
ten there may be a zero seven eleven
even
uh depending on what open pilot team
wants to do and there's also been a big
drain on kama's resources for a project
for the secret project that you guys
know nothing about
uh so you know that's where a lot of our
resources
have been going uh but when you guys see
it you're gonna be like
holy [ __ ] city almost
um nah shit's unreal but
for now enjoy your zero seven nine
zero seven nine is a solid release you
do not
want features you want stability and bug
fixes trust me
everyone who thinks they want features
has no idea what something
why is open pilot i drove i drove i did
a road trip
i drove thousand miles that was four
thousand miles
at least three thousand somewhere
between three and four thousand
and open pilot is so
good hyundai sonata i'm doing like
mountain roads up in colorado i got the
thing engaged
it doesn't make mistakes um pay
attention at all times of course i was
paying attention at all times
uh but you know hours just watch the car
drive so chill
um if you have a supported car and you
don't have a comma two
why comma twos are great
uh buy one um and you know the comma two
the comma two is gonna be around for
quite a while
uh we just ordered i just ordered
another two thousand
uh i just approved the order for another
two thousand of everything today
um we've sold about 2 500 of them right
now
did i sit in the back seat no don't do
that degenerate [ __ ]
um no i sat in the driver's seat with my
seatbelt buckled and i watched the world
go by
uh min iq needed to work at com we don't
actually iq test
um but you know there's a real there's a
real truth to that we're looking for
intelligence and motivation
um and that's in every employee who
works at comma
um you got to be intelligent you got to
be motivated
uh will it help eons as well if you have
an
eon and a black panda yeah if you don't
have a black panda
uh get a black panda he owns with black
pandas
they're eventually gonna be deprecated
but we're in no rush
because it's very easy i saw on twitter
people were like bring back support for
white panda
we're never gonna bring back support for
white panda and let me explain why
all right do you want us to bring up you
see i'm not a no child left behind guy
right
i'm not trying to bring up the base i'm
not trying to bring up the freon with a
white panda person
i'm trying to bring up the comma 2
person right i'm trying to bring up the
high end
so i'm not gonna deprecate things just
because i want more money from you i
mean i do want more money from you but
that's not why things get deprecated
right we have a plan for that we're
gonna release a medium post you have one
year of support
if you buy hardware from us now you have
a one year warranty on it
and you can expect that that hardware is
going to continue to run
open pilot for one more year um
beyond that you know
i mean look we're not apple we can't
support io we can't support the iphone 6
right i mean android you don't even get
support for a year
be happy if you get an update right um
but it's not done it's not done because
we're trying to you know take money from
you guys
god i don't care about that um it's done
because
it takes effort for us to continue to
support that old code
right if we want to bring up the high
end well
think about it right when we write the
new params learner and the reason why
pandas got deprecated
um is because the new params learner
needs a high precision gps it doesn't
initialize without a high precision gps
it won't learn the parameters without a
high precision gps
well could we write a version of it that
works with white pandas we could
but why should that be where we invest
engineering time
right it shouldn't and also remember
10x better than most companies if you
want to invest the time
you can right it's open source if you
want to invest the time to backport the
new params learner to white pandas you
can
um you want to get a cheap supported car
for common it's all pretty cheap right
it's all pretty cheap
um i'm hoping that the zero eight models
are going to be
mind-blowing uh
3d what i've been working on guys you
heard of batch normalization
you know what i came up with yesterday
unbatched normalization the layer is
called
denormalize and it's literally batch
normalized in reverse
and it works um you know
if i wasn't lazy i'd write it up in a
paper but uh
this is all the summary you get
basically take your running mean and
your running variance
uh put some momentum on that and just
instead of subtracting and dividing
add and multiply right denormalize batch
norm
turns inputs into mean zero variance one
right on the output denormalized takes
zero
mean one variance inputs and turns them
into whatever the real outputs are
so yeah if you're a machine learning
researcher and you're doing regression
check out the denormalized layer
i'm very excited about denormalize just
a little
little new tweak in our new models i
mean you guys can decompile the models
when they come out
we switched it's all in pi torch now
it's so easy in tensorflow
so in tensorflow it became pretty easy
to do multiple gpus in the same machine
um in pi torch two things are different
tensorflow used a
single process to feed all eight gpus
it's terrible you know because i have to
get so much bandwidth through that
process
if you do mem copy mem copy only works
at like 2 gigabytes per second
memcap is pathetic compared to the
memory bandwidth of your computer
um unpopular opinion use batch norm
after activation
what get out boo get out
uh i don't know what kind of activate
using swishes using swishes
yeah you probably swish um
now look um denormalize
forget what i was talking about oh yeah
distributed data parallel in pi torch
it creates a process for each gpu it is
so much better it uses basically raw
nickel to synchronize the weights across
the things
and it's free to go across multiple
machines
we got a we got a 400 gigabit we got we
had
two hundred gigabit infiniband cards in
each one of our gpu machines that's 400
gigabits from each of the five machines
going into an infiniband switch
i'm training it we the bandwidth is so
overkill we didn't need any of that
the 100 gigabit into our main switch
would have been fine but
you know we get to play with infiniband
right yeah it's super sweet
uh so yeah we got five machines on this
on the sick infiniband setup
and yeah the model that i'm training
right now it's training right now but
you know
it's so nice we trained our vision
models like the vision model that's in
uh it's still the same one from zero
seven six um that vision model
was trained that took like ten days to
train
now on our four gpu machine on a four
gpu rig we train them in two
um denormalize makes things a little
faster too
takes two days to to get these models to
work we'll probably do a fine tune of
the model for another two days
but uh it's still it's super nice um
yeah is your seven x move over for semi
yeah
yeah you know you can already do that if
you
really want to do that you can already
comment out the lanes but it doesn't
drive as
stable uh what torque limitations do you
have a honda
there's really not torque limitations on
the hyundai's and toyotas
toyotas have other issues toyotas have
[ __ ] angle sensors
and they seem to lag but other than that
uh
really buy a hyundai hyundai that
you get torque and you get oh you got
honda torque well
how many of you guys have torque mods
now you know as long as you're keeping
it as long as you're doing it safely
you guys doing it safely with the torque
mods
uh if you're doing it safely with the
torque mods torque mod gang right
you know we can't release that uh we
can't release the torque mods uh we
can't even really like
you know look i don't wanna get sued by
honda man
um but if you guys figure it out hey
[ __ ] you know you can modify your own
car
i can't release honda's proprietary
firmware that's copyright infringement
so we don't do things like that
but if you guys figure it out more power
to you it's nice that people have
figured out torque mods
um yeah
make a discord server
comma has a discord server the problem
with the discord server was moderation
moderation's a hard problem across the
internet now so we just clamped down on
all talk that wasn't like
very clearly related to comma and it's
made the moderation much easier
you know what am i gonna hire a
full-time discord moderator who
understands the nuance of the community
think i got a budget for that i don't
um no bosh accord mod yet i think we
have one of those
i think we have a bosch record mod um
wilm has a bosch accord so hello
uh
today is a great day to buy a comma two
if you didn't buy a comma two today is a
great day to buy one
uh if you want to come work at comma two
things
we're hiring we're hiring people who we
don't usually hire um you want to build
you want to build apps
come work at common someone's got to
make a common connect app good we have
the budget for it now right we got
we got you know 2 500 comma 2 users to
support
i don't have a coupon look i'm sitting
on a bench you think i got a coupon
yeah i can pull a coupon out of my ass
what you think i had a coupon
oh god [ __ ] um i don't even have a
shopify my phone
in what certain uh situation is is dnorm
useful so dnorm is useful
when your outputs do not have um
mean zero and variance one and you're
like why don't you just rescale the
outputs well if you have multi-headed
gaussian
predictors just rescaling the outputs
would only give you one rescale where
example for example
we've announced this we have five plans
in the new model we want each one of the
five plans to have a separate
learned mean adjustment
um you can't program see if you start
out with that if you start out with like
i can't
probably not i mean we're hiring for an
office manager who we do not expect to
program
but we expect to have very high
conscientiousness and intelligence right
uh we're hiring we're hiring app
developers
we're hiring ui oh come on someone needs
to clean up the open pilot ui we need a
ui
developer um you make games you want to
make games it's the sickest game ever it
drives the cars right
um well i can't talk about the secret
project it's a secret
if i talked about the secret project it
wouldn't be a secret anymore
you know um kama's working on stuff
behind the scenes the secret project
uh the model is not the secret project
we're working on 3d models and pie torch
just popped in any ground rules for
questions if you're asking me questions
about me
that's the wrong place to ask if you're
asking questions about common i ask
whatever
um multi-cam
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa we are not near
the limits of the single camera yet
we haven't even shipped big model yet um
i don't know about big model there's a
lot of other problems before big model
why does the car not slow down for turns
my sister my sister came to visit me
last weekend she's like
but can't you just like you know like
like like like make something that can
like look at the turn and tell you what
speed you should take it at because like
all the humans who drove took the turn
at that speed and i'm like
yeah that sounds really smart now
actually build it we're working on it
0.8
um narrow wide main cameras whoa
whoa who's got all these fancy cameras
one camera
two cameras comma two it's got two
cameras
you know it's got a forward camera and a
backward camera
yeah whoa whoa
look at all these fancy cameras all i'm
saying if they're ever going to be more
cameras are going to be very expensive
um how good are our maps maps are
useless
maps are useless um we're getting all
the outputs from the new stuff if we
ever do want to make them
but you know someone wants to come here
and work on maps and you're smart i'll
hire you
um i think maps are kind of useless but
like we have the best
we have we have devices that are
gathering stuff that's like centimeter
accurate like if someone wants to stitch
that together and throw that into an hd
map and put deep map and all those sad
companies out of business
[ __ ] i'll hire you what's my take on
waymo going live
what do you mean is it live can i hire a
huevo if i download the app right now
can i hire a weima
um red light detection is the wrong way
to think about it ghost hardware is
vaporware uh nvidia buying arm
thumbs down thumbs up to risk five um
in in in phonics in phonics so i can go
to phonics and i can get a wemo
um
what do i care about the rimac concept
too hardware subscription model oh my
god
ghost's ridiculous subscription model
um it's another fake launch waymo is
going to be fake launches
until they go out of business right
the problem with waymo isn't even
technical the problem with waymo is
product
you're paying for a slower uber you're
paying less money for a slower uber i
have news for you
you can already do this it's called
uberpool
um oh yeah yeah i believe that that
reddit video yeah that's really a
community reddit video waymo you fooled
me
oh gotta make it look like we gotta make
it look like it's coming from the
community and it's not paid actors
never mind we're not here to talk about
waymo we're here to talk about winners
um we'll go for 30 minutes we got we got
we got eight more minutes for questions
on honesty friday night honesty
friday night uh
come over get into the wallpaper
business i don't think so
any improvements on wobble well you're
gonna get improvements on wobble sooner
so
wobble or ping pong happens because um
we don't have uh i don't care about the
enemy trust hearings
we don't basically every time you reduce
latency
and you increase um real-timeness you
reduce wobble
how do you decide when to be honest yeah
it's friday night it's a good time for
being honest
wait seven nine wobbles more than the
previous no way
no way you'll show that to me in some
repeatable way and we'll look into it
i don't believe um
i've been driving around on zero nine
best quality autopilot
it's still friday night here this is
california common europe is doing well
common europe's doing well we got three
people over there uh if you're
interested in joining common europe of
course
email in it wobbled a bit what car
home pilot 1.0 you know like never make
any mistakes and be perfect
uh i'm driving the canada yeah yeah i'm
driving the canada sonata biggest
failure of
2020 um
[Music]
i don't know we were out of stock for a
while on comma twos
production took a bit to get under
control production's going really well
now
uh did any company fork open piling yeah
there's chinese knockoffs of comma twos
um i mean ghost and mercedes are gonna
knock off open pilot at some point they
just don't know it yet
there's great companies like epilogue
um oh there's all there's a malaysian
fork of open pilot
some kid in korea made bank selling
knock-off combinations
is common mission focused like coinbase
you mean do i care about
you know is comma going to come out in
favor of of [ __ ] political
initiatives no
um was i serious when i said i'd train
the net on waze
like kind of um the problem
is like running ways and then what if
they update it
uh we need to build our own navigation
we're hiring for that
please come work here please build it
how do i hear about the korean knockoff
i hear about everything uh how will i
know if a big company uses open pilot
you don't think that thing is riddled
with botnets and phone home
things it is you can read the code and
you can look for it
we know everyone who's using it for
everything all right
is there a chinese competitor look let
me explain to you how competition works
here's the pie of after-market
self-driving systems right
every person who builds an after-market
self-driving system that's a competitor
with us they're not competing with us
they're not stealing
market share from us they're growing the
pie
right like like it seems like it's gonna
win
every new person who comes along is just
making the pie bigger and you know what
the great thing about big pies is
you can eat big pieces um big pieces of
big pies
you're going to win well did android win
tesla's going to win ah
open pilot is great there's a lot
there's a lot of room for improvement
you know oh man
if i could drive with open pilot 1.0
right now
it'd be great
no you don't understand the layman
doesn't understand or doesn't trust c
this is a myth people think it's like oh
i gotta dumb my [ __ ] down for the lowest
common denominator no you don't
there's people who do that for you right
it's it's it's it's trickle d
everything's trickled down
everything good is trickle down right
[ __ ] man
who had smartphones before smartphones
who had pdas running windows ce where
you could buy the cell phone adapter
card that was like yay big and put in
your
2g edge sim card so you could get whap
you know before the cardi b
song right like
we had that i don't know i don't know if
you're the wii but i had that [ __ ]
you know 2002 right that's who had
you know i had a pda you opened up the
little thing and you could stick a phone
wire in there
and you could connect to a dial-up
service through your your
your your flip top pda right
that's how this all works
you know it's not it's not the thing the
new thing is around for
10 years before the normies get it you
guys are here you know
everyone is buying comma twos and you
know all the future comma [ __ ]
like you guys are on board with a with a
revolution and you're like oh the
revolution's never going to happen it's
gonna be embedded in the cars
yeah man and motorola is still making
cell phone os's right
no wait they're not does motorola even
still exist
i think i think google bought them for
their patents or some [ __ ]
right
what benz and audi
no
have you been in those cars have you
used those systems they're [ __ ]
if anything the only other reasonable
system out there is super cruise
right and you're like oh they have the
secret good version no they don't
guys let me let you in on a little
secret you know the secret version of
open pilot like we talk about it com is
driving around the secret version of
open pilot
it doesn't exist there is no secret good
version of
anything anywhere because if it did
exist the company would have shipped it
yeah man you can buy zoops go on amazon
get a zooks delivered to your house
don't worry it drives backwards and
forwards we got you both ways
what if i want to drive sideways need a
callow platform
bmw was trying to sell subscription
eating seats
yeah i saw them as funny as [ __ ] um
what's mao love donuts
what is will's honda mod is it unsafe
don't do anything unsafe uh
if someone kidnapped you can you make a
self-driving missile
not build an iron man suit i bust out
man george hearts made this in a
basement with a bag of scraps
that's right um nah it's all just pr
oh what's our monthly active users uh i
think like 30
duh it's above 3 000
might be at 3 500 now
um any progress on pure vision i mean
it's all coming with the new models
new models will come
iron man suit i don't know arc reactors
seem pretty hard to make you know we're
paying for power here
actually less than i thought but it's
still 25 cents a kilowatt hour
we're running the new segment we're
running the new segnet right now across
all the segments
you know we're going to fix up some
stuff with the new segment thank you 10k
uh contributors uh and that segnet run
is going to cost us 600
in power are people doing actual pull
request good pull request shout out to
dean lee teen lee's doing great pull
requests
um do investors ever call begging to
give you more money
a16z doesn't really like us uh
well i don't know you know chris dixon
hey man if i you know
said crypto was the future and crypto
went the way it went i mean it's like
yeah i got into 20k now it's down to 10
but don't worry it's gonna go up
um no look i don't mean to rip on a16z
but no we don't talk to them anymore
uh do people email in like every day to
invest in comma of course but what would
i do with their money
buy a yacht right should we raise a
billion dollars and buy a yacht
and just live on our yacht and be like
yo kama's just this yacht
uh no because that'd be irresponsible
with the investors money and i'd never
do that
we're a profitable company we make money
by providing value to you
uh [ __ ] man you know our product costs
twelve hundred dollars
and once people get it set up and start
using it they're like oh my god this
thing how did i ever live without it
um would boston dynamics or any non-car
company have used for a comma product
probably not
all twitch subs invited to chill on the
yacht let's go san diego let's go we're
going to sail out we're going to
we're going to uh hawaii you know it
costs like six grand in fuel to get to
hawaii
i can drive across the country for like
you know
100 bucks in fuel in my prius uh like is
that actually right let's say hundred
dollars
let's say two dollars a gallon let's be
generous 50 gallons
60 all right fine fine 200 bucks in fuel
right
um but still six grand to get your yacht
and fuel to hawaii what do you need to
know you need to be intelligent
motivated uh open yacht all right let's
support it man let's port it
we're at a space yo did you guys know
that you can just like book a spacex
rocket on spacex.com
they give you their prices and we went
to this data center company
and they couldn't give us their prices
no no no you got a call you got to
request the quote but if you want a
rocket launch
just go to spacex.com and you can book
one how unreal is that
um you know i hate when things are like
oh contact us for pricing
spacex will just tell you the pricing
for a rocket no contact us
i'm kidding about the 2 billion honestly
if i didn't respect them
and they offered me 2 billion i'd be
like [ __ ] off with your fake fed coin
uh seeing a lot of quality issues on
discord it's
a lot because of more users um i mean
we're selling we're selling you know
we're selling three times as many as we
were last year right
so you're gonna see three times as many
complaints i think also what people have
come to expect is a bit higher
uh but we're tracking the quality issues
we're we're
we're they've been getting better
they've been trending upward over time
the quality has not been trending
downward i can definitely say
updates to our museum approach yeah it's
we're working on dreamer v2 no i have to
read that
uh i don't know what the deal is i don't
know if that happened people at comma
last for like a month
uh is there a new product in the works
i mean there's always new products in
the works you guys see the obd2 harness
that thing's sick right yeah i'm never
contacting for pricing
100 billion um what are the personal
costs from being famous i'm not famous
but i got 136 people in here you all
think i'm famous
uh when can you leave your comment to
the texas heat and not have it burned up
zero seven ten with the down clock cpu
i'm not watching any sports ball
um i don't know what a tc is man i don't
know anything about tc do i miss doing
presentations
yeah kind of i don't know just vacations
do i miss vacation sure
you know everyone comes to me they're
like well i can really learn something
from this conference the company should
pay for me to go i'm like company's not
going to pay and if you want to go it's
a vacation i mean you can
go that's what i how i treat it you know
when i gave that berkeley presentation
you know why i went because they put me
up in the claremont for two nights that
hotel's sick
um what are you being for halloween
not anything inappropriate that's right
um
are the down clocks in master ci yet no
they're part of the new version of neo s
um oh
dehazabus far over sam altman
uh all right that's off topic question
do we have any other questions about
comma if we have any other questions
about comma i'll answer them
uh if we don't
do i already have a memorial day isn't
that in may
uh custom silicon probably not
uh you don't really need i mean if no
company can provide us what we want sure
uh conferences are a scam
common mileage is way back up i mean you
can go on you can go on
any of the websites that track traffic
uh covet is mostly over
um the reason lcm we use a groove
oh the quality bar is super high for
common pencil i know
um i mean yeah the new segnet
the new segment the segment that i'm
running right now that i'm paying 600
in power to run is 2x better than the
previous segment
that means for every mistake the number
of mistakes is literally
half which is unreal um
yeah the the core shielding kind of
works it's a kernel tweak
it's gonna be in zero seven ten ah
when will common be available in india
we ship worldwide
longitudinal on hkg don't run the forks
they're not good they aren't good and
nobody's read any of that safety code
yet
um they if they're interested they
should try to upstream that safety code
that's the first thing to do get it
upstreamed into panda
uh what city you're in we're in san
diego we're in beautiful san diego in
the san diego
city college campus right here um you
think com is already perfect for highway
no good yo so i took lex for a ride and
we did some driving around the city and
he's like
this is really good and i'm like yeah
that's what i said
uh congrats on the new segment
deployment thank you
we're running it right now it's burning
power right now at the common office
uh oh the commercial segmentation
i know i mean you see the commercial
segmentation that we paid for
uh i mean they're working on they got to
get the quality act together though
uh like i'm the volunteers have really
been catching the bugs and i really
appreciate that
because you have to get the look every
other company is just using the
commercial companies and they're
accepting it you think any employee
there is actually looking through each
piece of data guys i really appreciate
you
you know you guys the reason open pile
is going to be so good
um any case we see regressions not
really
comma can't drive in india people don't
follow rules don't worry about that it
doesn't matter
you need new projects on twitch uh
oh lex alexander talk about his company
i like his his social network idea
um deforests are the 10 second limit i
don't think new ones do but i'm not sure
anyone has confirmed that
traffic lights and stop signs are
largely a gimmick if done wrong i don't
like the way tesla did it with maps
we're never going to ship it with maps
next interview is over uh yeah the comet
is way way better on roads without lane
markers compared to tesla
of course yeah like that is really where
that is what we've been working on what
do we what do we talk about we talk
about end to end
it's working the thing i promised on the
last last lex interview
about being able to drive without lanes
like it's mostly there
tss 2.5 should not be hard if anybody
has a tss 2.5 car here's my here's my
here's my challenge deal
if anybody has a tss 2.5 car and you
want to come down to san diego
you want to come hang out for a couple
days we'll do the port i think it's
super easy
um volunteers are selected for actually
caring yeah i mean we care
karma is selected for actually caring
you think people call up and like they
answer the questions right and then like
i ask them and they just don't care you
think i'm gonna hire them no
uh can i explain the open pilot
architecture read the code
um how can i get in contact with you
you're in contact with me right now if
you expect me to send an email and talk
privately
here's the bar for private here's the
bar for public it's way lower come on i
answered a question about like
you know uh uh coinbase is
whatever approach you know who does the
carports at comma now
yeah we get around to them open power
team is pretty busy with like
you know the high leverage stuff but we
will do tss 2.5 that carport is very
important to me
other carports not so important to me oh
yeah you can pay me a thousand bucks if
you really want a phone call
thoughts on using transformer models for
vision lex asked me this too
and i said yeah we'll try them i i mean
i think
driving is way more markovian than the
language sometime when you're parsing a
sentence
you have to like think like oh what was
in the paragraph three paragraphs ago
you almost never have to think of what
happened 30 seconds ago when you're
driving
um because driving is way more markovian
so i think stuff like we use a group i
think a group is fun
uh we'll y'all release the training code
no we will not
the training code is comma's secret
private ip
and the thing about the training code is
if i thought it could help you know joe
and jane
open source yes i would absolutely
release it it does not help joan jane
open source
we are training everything on a half
million dollar super computer that would
cost you 5 million to rent in the cloud
like what can i tell you right like it
would not be useful for you to have the
training code
at all do you have 32 gpus ready to go
do you have like two petabytes of
spinning disks
half a petabyte of ssds right like this
is the scale that things are happening
at
and the training code will only help out
companies and [ __ ] companies
that's right if companies want to work
with me
they can have a phone call for one
thousand dollars
how do you get 32 gpus the gpu store
um yeah i know attention is all you need
hey look
that stuff was in people were like oh
this is some radical new idea that exact
same idea
was in pack eight for the hutter price
uh which company do i hate the most i'm
upset with nvidia
i think jensen should follow his heart
and not his mbas
uh you want a 30-90 so bad yeah me too i
do have four 30 80s though
play some sick games on them we spaced
them out we spaced them out a bit you
know
uh can i explain in layman's terms why
labeling lines accurately is important
beyond model doesn't really use any
lanes
um they're used for benchmarking they're
used to determine like whether our
thing is thinking correctly they're
going to be used for mapping
and they're also used for like uh
alignment
so like one of the things that you can
do super accurately with lanes is like
you can check your calibration right
because if you're if you're sliding at
all your lanes are gonna
are gonna slide right but if your
calibration is perfect your lanes are
gonna be perfect
um so we use lanes for a lot of like
uh like like like ground truthy like
tasks
uh not necessarily for training the
final policy model
but you know what is your actions right
you're still going to have to recover
those you want to do semi-supervised
learning you still have to recover those
the lanes and also it's not just lanes
remember the segment is also movable we
have to filter movable
out um in order to be able to use orb
features to recover the pose
all right so that's why
um can you what company holds a youtube
live like this
none of them because they're oh we got
to run that by the pr
department oh we got to make sure that
the ceo doesn't leak any new stuff
uh why am i at the college campus yeah
i'm going in there to recruit right
after this
um schmidt uber gets all the credit uh
i don't know who richard hart is can my
computer's running crisis yeah probably
elaine's are the original sin of comma
it's true but no we've
we've gone beyond lanes um
manufacturers aren't contacting us they
are but they're not contacting us
correctly
they're contacting us with the wrong
kind of people asking the wrong kind of
questions
i'll tell you what's going to happen
those manufacturers are going to have
teams of engineers
who start to incorporate open pilot and
those people are going to reach out to
me
and those people i'm going to want to
talk to the people who want to
can we figure out some way that we can
work together
no if you don't know what you want from
me i don't want to work with you
um because george is the company in the
advertising team the soup nazi policy
yes that's right no open pilot for you
no open pilots for everybody
who understands how to read code open
pilot's not for people who think they
have to talk to somebody
uh no i'm not flipping the phone uh
the pr department yeah yeah yeah press
secretary right
internal press secretary what is up with
the shields for swift for machine
learning it's stupid
um someone just needs to make
past python some critical master cars
blah blah blah is tesla watching
who's tesla is elon watching this i
think he's watched some of the comment
yeah
archive clips but he's probably not
watching right now i'm pretty much sure
he's not watching right now
um new segments help lead car detection
to help with that too
what tiny car oh we go i don't know man
we realized that partnerships were
stupid uh
sutton bartow i don't know who that is
can i do 10 push-ups yeah
but i'm holding a phone not while i'm
holding a phone i can't do 10 one-armed
push-ups
what company do i hate the least you'd
think how could you how could you hate
spacex man
how could you hate the company that's
literally going to like bring people to
mars
you can't hate them is go laying fast
yeah going's fast
way faster than python um
i am not voting in 2020.
uh oh the popular oral book i read that
book yeah it's pretty good
why is radar so bad at the technostatic
objects it's not but you have to filter
them out because it gets false positives
um
what about blue origins no it's just
bezos trying to show off his dick size
uh no i don't i don't know that about
blue origin um
ordered a comma two for your card they
ship mondays and thursdays
no what's our next major milestone zero
eight is a big milestone
all right all right all right i'll let
you win i'll let you in on a spoiler
this is not my spoiler the team was
working on it and i put my foot down and
said
no but maybe it'll happen for zero eight
we're thinking of turning the blue to
black
we're thinking of turning the blue to
black what do y'all think about that
uh so that might happen
that might happen i've seen some
mock-ups of the blue or the black
black looks very nice uh
the seven zero seven eleven maybe it
depends it depends on if research team
gets their act together
uh and makes
good stuff and gets the model zero eight
is the new model so zero eight it will
be called zero eight once we have the
new model
pi torch 3d way more data than ever
before
free slurpee version
maps are going to be so accurate that
you can drop a railroad tie
and you'll be within the railroad tie
it's actually pretty accurate
do i think i'm changing the world no do
i think the world is changing
we're always changing it's just so weird
to think that we're
always changing it's in a real friend's
song
all right all right if we're up to
complaining about spacex
name then we're over how many segments
is new segnet trained on oh you mean the
model called new segnet
oh it's interesting you call that model
oh that new segnet um
i don't think that many i don't know
uh yeah we're releasing our own car yeah
yeah the comma car
it'll only support the common car we're
gonna drop support for all the other
cars
only the copper car no we're not making
a car
open pallet ever going to be a phone app
no not officially
we don't have enough control
this maps are helpful for some things
mostly navigation
who cares about ghost ghost doesn't
knock off commas three years behind um
you know here's what i'll say about
ghost
ghost there's like a
what is it it's like the the the maybe
the donning kruger effect or one of
those things
where someone is like like they don't
know what they don't know
um but you know i'll leave when i see it
any new comma prime features in the
pipeline when you come here and work on
them
um right now there is sadly nobody
working on common prime features
common prime is kind of sad i know i
know buy it anyway support us
no i mean it works for what it is but i
want new features i really
want new features if you want to come
here and work on those new features
we'd love to hire you um give me a job
at com
ai work at common ai or if you're
really if you think you're really good
but only if you're really good you can
email georgia common ai
ah yeah
thank you all for watching my stream
well if elon admits that it's not
happening then people are going to be
like i want my money back for full self
driving elon
uh ghost isn't here
you enjoy your isabelle man enjoy
yourself
uh you do need a new job hey come here
it's a nice place to work
yeah flagged events for the
accelerometer yeah common security i
want to do that yeah yeah yeah yeah
the first pioneers but the second common
profits ghost is 3 500
no ghost isn't 3 500 ghost
isn't real stop falling for
[ __ ] i could put up a website saying
that i'm going to sell you a jet pack
for 3 500
we're taking pre-orders now jet pack
easy to fly nobody's ever crashed
yeah nobody's ever crashed because we
didn't make any damn jet pack
right believe things when you see them
don't believe it because there's a
website
uh yeah we just posted a new bounty all
you literally have to do
is get python to build on your comma two
and be patient enough to wait 12 hours
for the optimizations
um i'm sure jet packs are real
i've never seen one
uh is mla holistic field i don't
understand the question
is that light blinking on and off i
believe so
oh [ __ ] actually that's a good point if
ghost is charging 3500
damn are things real we can charge at
least 3
000 i think we should raise the price
should i go raise the price tomorrow
comma 2 29.99 it's 500
cheaper than fake ghost it's real and
500 cheaper what do y'all think better
buy your comma twos right now i might
just
i might just [ __ ] around and raise the
price
compared to our compared to our fake
competitor
this is charging 3500 but something
isn't real
you can get your comment to right now
for 29.99
plus plus 199 for the harness of course
so it does come out to 3200 all said and
done
but hey it's still 300 bucks cheaper
than ghost
i'm going to raise the price tomorrow
are you allowed to do drugs in common no
i mean i don't want to know about it you
guys always think i'm on drugs i'm
really not
um you will sell your old comma 2 for
1.5 k
on ebay yeah appreciating asset
it's an appreciating asset
uh you're allowed to work on your own
projects no
you're here because you want to work and
solve self-driving cars can you go work
on your own projects in your own time
and your own [ __ ]
sure um
please raise the price see that's what
i'm liking [ __ ] i think it really might
go up
should we just make it should we just
make it like 11.99
starting on saturday and see what
happens
i think after we release zero eight the
price is gonna go up
that's what we're gonna do for black
friday instead of a discount
it's gonna be you know we're gonna raise
the price
uh do common employees have to sign an
nda of course
what it's a normal company
oh use the computer after work time at
comma what you really want to use at the
com
i'm not even answering this um do you
need to know about open pilot when you
apply for a job it definitely helps
yeah we're going to increase the price i
love raising the price yeah we'll meme
someone into making an article about it
could they please just talk about how
even at 29.99
we're still 500 cheaper than ghost and
we're real
gang gang comment in stocks
wow this almost went for an hour
such a deal that's right so if we raise
the price people just think they're
getting more value that's what i'm
talking about
no you can't work remote well the remote
employees we ever hired were slackers
no remote employees
um
like buying bitcoin 10 years ago yo you
could buy like 10 comma 2s right now
will we raise the price and then resell
them on ebay just like 1080s
sorry sorry 3080s and 30 90s you know
yeah we're recruiting of course it's a
normal company you work here you get
paid you get equity and you join the
winning team
uh microsoft permanently last year do i
look like microsoft
expensive take cake tastes better than
cheap i love you guys goading me into
raising the price i'm gonna do it
tomorrow
my go i'm gonna you know what [ __ ] i'm
gonna work right now i'm gonna raise the
shopify
no they're 9.99
you get a good deal san diego is better
than
san francisco's dying do we ask lead
code of course
of course be prepared be prepared to
code
comma bundle with random things that
just might happen are you interested in
a 60 pound cyber power ups
we're going to sell you guys remember
the bag of crap on woo we're gonna sell
comma bags of crap whatever around the
office
are you interested in a hundred
honda nidak giraffes you just might get
that in the comma bag of crap
um
oh you need part 300x investment no no
no no no no the world's still getting
around to believing parts one and two
uh you are you interested are you
interested in a hundred honda night act
giraffes
email me an offer and i'll hook you up
um not my city san francisco's dying i
moved out
you watched my regex stream
you convinced investors you think any
investors we got a profit
we convinced people to buy it because
[ __ ] man
even at 29.99 we're still 500 that are
uh cheaper than our cheaper than our
closest fake competitor
all right all right we gotta end the
stream at some point
i like your questions i like the energy
in this stream this is honesty friday
nights
um you know come work at comma tell your
friends man
join the winning team you know you get
it now you'll get rich you get in later
you won't get rich you think you can get
rich now working for microsoft
you can't you join now you watch us take
over the world you get rich
and you build something sick you know
this thing
the comma 2 is a new class of consumer
electronics
sure it's a 3d printed phone and a case
but like you know what is an ipad but an
iphone just made a little bit bigger new
class
um the new nvidia chips are great can i
buy them
no got to buy them from scalpers on ebay
you'll be buying coming to some scalpers
on ebay after i raise the price to 29.99
uh no we're not hiring for i.t
just for usa we ship worldwide worldwide
anywhere in the world
we will ship you a comma too
open pilot is game changing that's right
to turkey i'll ship to turkey i'll ship
that anyway i don't think i can ship
iraq and iran if it is illegal for us to
ship to you from america we will not
ship to you
i don't think we can ship to cuba but
anywhere else fair game
i'll ship you whatever i don't care
reporting open pile to golang wait you
don't like python
the python it barely even runs python
palettes written in c plus plus
i don't think we're allowed to ship to
north korea i don't know if anyone has
29.99 in disposable income to buy a
comma 2 with
[Music]
no no we do everything legal boys
there's no geo-fencing it's open source
software it's commonwealth on another
country streets no it detects if they're
non-american streets and turns off
of course it works we even have a toggle
so you can drive on the left like the
brits i think we could ship to morocco
yeah
is money a problem for a startup not
when you're making bank because you got
a sick product that everyone wants to
buy for 29.99 um
okay all right all right all right we
got we got it's nice to make these
things around
hour we got two more minutes with the
seville theater
check out city boxing
of course we shipped to canada we got a
lot of canadian users you know
someone's got to get to their hockey
game we got you open pilot
what else the canadians do you gotta go
tap your trees and get some maple syrup
yeah we got you open pilot
do a backflip i can't do a backflip i
can do 10 push-ups but not with a phone
in my hand
i did hear a nice song about how canada
is really big
yeah we shipped to australia of course
can i go buy a sandwich yeah probably
probably have to walk a bit more
downtown to get a sandwich
i don't know what park ore is but
parkour yeah sure why not
thoughts on waymo's pr push yeah
seen it before i do 20 push-ups sorry
you're pushing it
uh when you're ready to sell to
dealerships we are never gonna hire
sales people
that's never gonna happen
no one wants some massive sensors they
want a small little comma two sized
package
try a backboard
uh look
all i learned from gym class heroes is
all press is good press kids
you know see but you want to be famous
like kanye west you don't want to be
famous like oprah
yeah you know that that's not this is a
comma stream we're here to talk about
comment and we got 20 more seconds
i'll count you guys off
important big boy um op comma setups as
a service i think there's a few now
don't be a noob i don't know you'll have
to ask lex friedman about when that's
going up
but um thank you all for joining honesty
friday nights
zero eight coming soon zero seven nine
just came out open pilot
gets better all cars that can ota
stay the same and we're out doing a back
flip in five
four three two wait